[Music]
i have long maintained
that open source is not simply a vendor
you don't have to pay
because in practice even though the
source code itself is freely available
you do have to contribute back in some
way in order to ensure the long-term
sustainability of these projects
could you tell us a little bit more
about how tesco gives back
to the open source community so yeah so
i think um tesco
as an organization has supports open
source in a number of different ways and
i'll
i'll probably talk a little bit more
about the from a data
perspective since that's the area that i
work within so
you know we've done some things that are
very like obviously clear so like we've
sponsored
pi data london for for a number of years
and we've spoke at these conferences
um we have a number of uh members of our
teams who
regularly attend the the meetups um as
well as
obviously the odd pull requests here and
there or
kind of um making sure that any kind of
bugs or issues that we find
are reported back to the community and
kind of helping shape the direction
of of travel for the various products
that we're
um involved in so yeah i think that is
something that
is very nice in the open sources you do
feel like you can have a voice
i think opposed to some of the um you
know software that you just
kind of will buy from from a company is
that with within
the open source community you know if
you're if you want to you can get
involved you can help shape it you can
move it in the direction that you want
to
and so i think that's something that's
obviously it's so powerful
was it the case that tesco was bought
into
open source scientific computing tools
for its data science and machine
learning stack from the very start
or was there a journey in convincing
folks within tesco to embrace these
tools yeah so i think um
tesco like a lot of other kind of big
corporations have like historically
really relied on kind of partnerships
with big software providers where we pay
for the infrastructure in the data
infrastructure
i think recently we've seen a really big
shift in the approach
of how we approach building products
and tesco technology is really moving
towards a
kind of open cir open source first
approach
and i think especially in the data world
so i've been fortunate enough that at my
time at tesco
i've been able to see the growth of our
data platform
and it's really matured and it's
entirely built on top of open source
technologies
and it's allowed us to build great data
science products for the organization
while also kind of reducing the costs
that you know would be typically
associated with
using kind of paid for solutions from
external companies
[Music]
you